welcome back to safety roads the take
we're joined now by Gina Miller the
campaigner and founder of the tactical
voting website remain united thank you
very much for being on the program this
morning and you have been doing some
really interesting polling some number
crunching to try and work out what on
earth is going to happen in this
extremely unpredictable election and so
thanks for coming on the program to kind
of talk us through some of it I'll just
get up the first slide shall I just so
to use as a prop for the discussion this
is the voting intention that you did so
if you look at this it looks pretty good
news for the concept of party does it it
does look for a majority if there was an
election tomorrow so this is based on
the latest problem we got back on Friday
which actually is in line with some of
these of average ones so we've got eight
they're conservatives eight sent ahead
but that translates of the the magic
number to get to is 325 to get in form a
government and that actually only gives
them 12 seats majority I was pretty it's
all to play for really it's very tight
and we were seeing that narrowing and
just another 2% narrowing would reduce
that to actually a seventh seat loss so
the Delta if you like they call it at 1%
shift between or narrowing will mean
that conservatives lose nine seats and
labour gained eight so it's very very
tight and why is it narrowing happening
I mean the number that stands out to me
as well is the Liberal Democrats from 11
percent and is that why we've seen a
narrowing that you've seen Liberal
Democrat voters perhaps drifting back to
Lane it's really interesting in this
election because you've got the national
picture so we're doing sort of national
re MRP and polling but actually the
local picture in constituency is also
really important in this election and so
what we've done is we've done 71 MRP in
constituency polling an analysis and
there are many different reasons yes we
know that and the poll showed is that
the lead of the Lib Dems is not sort of
maybe landing as well as you could do
but there are definitely in constituency
factors playing out and for example I
know you had Dominic grab on earlier I
mean our tactical voting and what we're
picking up in his can
diction see is that the Lib Dem is
likely to win the candidate in that seat
rather than Dominic Raab because of
local issues not because of the national
picture extraordinaire anything that
he's the foreign secretary second most
powerful person in government let's have
a look at now at a couple of other bits
of data so this is the seat prediction
so this is effectively the seats that
you would get if tomorrow was carried
out yes and and if if no tactical voting
just based on voter intention at the
moment and where the polls are sitting
and the difference between the seats
there would be a 12 seat majority for
the Conservatives but but if people vote
tactically which I know is something
that new perhaps are encouraging this is
what would happen if people voted
tactically and that now we're in hung
parliament territory absolutely and so
what we're doing is we're giving people
recommendations and the poll the other
polling we did was on tactical voting
intention and what we're finding is that
it's staying stable at about 45% of
remain and softly voters saying that
they intend to tactically vote now we
saw that in 2017 when I ran that
campaign in 2017 we were on a tactical
voting campaign which saw 6.5 million we
know not just because of us but also 6.5
million people tactically voted if that
45% stays stable we get a hung
parliament with probably a three party
coalition I mean some of that views will
be listening to this thinking you are
somebody who campaigned for remain now
you're talking about tactically voting
are you just trying to stitch up this
election to stop brexit tactically
voting is actually not something new on
the political arena in the UK I mean all
the way back to 1997 we had tactical
voting and actually tactical voting
makes up for the deficit of the
first-past-the-post system and that's
where it's sort of this fills a gap but
tactical voting is happening on both
sides which is quite unusual from 2017
to this election because in 2017 we
weren't picking up as many leave out
tilt voters actually voting so both
sides are tactically voting and it is
about making sure your vote counts and
so the news from our poll is four remain
voters or soft levers
because it's both is that this is really
hopeful for you don't be disheartened
because you can actually create a hung
parliament to your desktop and authority
it does feed into what I've seen going
on the country as well I mean I'm going
to Grimsby and talking to people who
were brexit party supporters but we're
gonna vote conservative tactically to
try and stop Jeremy Corbyn coming in and
getting a second referendum and also in
Cheltenham this week as well people who
were Labour voters but we're gonna vote
live down because they thought they were
the best chance of beating the
conservative we've never seen voter
volatility as we're seeing in this
election and you know the sentiments
locally are very different but it's also
the fact that people are really picking
up on the fact that the
first-past-the-post system doesn't
really represent them when they go into
the polling booth so what they're going
to do is lend their vote to the party
where they know that in this system the
outcome is likely to be in fate the
favor that they want very quickly
because we're running out of time he
thinks what do you think is gonna happen
the election them empowerment concept a
majority what what do you think look
we're aiming United site we're making
recommendations if people follow that we
are in a hung parliament there is no
Tory majority another 2% narrowing that
is a looks as though it's almost a set
okay Jeannie Miller thanks very much
coming on and explaining that and
fascinating research to us thank you